oubliez les idées reçues jouer à la
pelote basque en touraine c'est possible
bayonnais d'origine julien martinez a
monté avec quelques amis une section au
sein de la spt tour l'histoire
probablement de ne pas se sentir trop
dépaysé la première impression que j'ai
eu un dépassement morneau et en envoyant
plus de fronts temps même si c'est
dommage parce qu'avec on parle beaucoup
de pelote basque
mais bon il n'est pas forcément que
masquer la pauvreté dans lequel peut
aussi s'exporter et c'est qu'en france
ça se joue beaucoup dans sud ouest mais
pas ailleurs et donc la volonté je me
suis dit ça parce que parce qu'on n'est
pas ce qu'on joue à la pelote
comment deux pays joués la pelote basque
est une expression générique qui
regroupe 24 disciplines différentes
ici pas de chistera on joue à la pala
avec une raquette plein les parties se
disputent en double c'est est le sport
le plus adapté à ce gymnase des
tourettes est en effet la pratique fait
des émules chez les tourangeaux j'ai
commencé très bas et je progresse
lentement quoi donc
donc maintenant on commence à pouvoir
s'amuser en tout cas quoi on commence à
pouvoir tenir les changes à faire à
prendre du plaisir à jouer en faites
quoi c'est pas trop saccadé les échanges
durent donc c'est ça qui est intéressant
après dans les sports de raquette corps
je pense qu'il faut bien dans l'esprit
du sport de pelote
c'est quoi l'esprit justement l'esprit
c'est pas le sportif consommateurs qui
vient juste consommer ip sa carte il
consomme s'en va c'est vraiment la
convivialité pouvoir voilà rester parlé
entre nous se connaître la sppt tour
compte 26 pts l'otarie qui espère bien
un jour remporté leur tournoi
ce dimanche les vainqueurs du 5e open
national gagneront un panier garni de
spécialités tourangelle pas de jambon de
bayonne ni de piment d'espelette et ça
c'est bien la preuve que la pelote
basque et s'implante en touraine